[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions du côté
de tours on retrouve Valérie Pernet
bonjour Valérie merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directrice départementale
adjointe de la Nouvelle République
Valérie on va commencer avec vous par en
parlant d'inflation puisque vous
proposez à vos lecteurs une série
d'articles autour d'inflation et de
pouvoir d'achat aujourd'hui vous parler
surendettement
oui tout à fait tout au long de cette
semaine nous nous intéressons au
touranjo face à l'inflation lundi nous
avons passé le budget de plusieurs
ménages au crible hier nous avons
cherché ou faire ses courses moins cher
et ce mercredi nous nous demandons
comment les tours enjaux payent-ils ces
hausse des prix nous sommes allés voir
du côté des banquiers l'interview du
directeur départemental adjoint de la
Banque de France nous apprend que sur
les trois premiers mois de l'année 314
dossiers de surendettement ont été
ouverts un chiffre qui est en hausse de
4,3% par rapport à l'année dernière
alors c'est moins élevé que la moyenne
nationale qui était la 6% environ ce
n'est donc pas un tsunami mais il faut
ajouter à ce constat un recours plus
élevé aux découvert les gens
reconsomment le découvert avec les
autorisations consenties depuis quelques
mois constatent le président
départemental de la Fédération bancaire
française il évoque une conjoncture
beaucoup moins favorable aujourd'hui
qu'il y a un an voir avant on se
souvient en effet que la période covid
avait été au contraire marquée par le
renforcement de l'épargne demain le
dossier inflation continue on
s'intéressera cette fois au vol de
nourriture dont le nombre augmente dans
les supermarchés
et Valérie on va parler d'un autre thème
avec vous ce sera le thème de ce club on
en parle beaucoup évidemment ce sont les
questions d'agression des lieux il y
aura une marche qui aura lieu
aujourd'hui à Saint-Brévin et vous allez
nous parler vous de l'agression du maire
de Cheillé
oui l'effet se sont produits à Chaillé
c'est une petite commune rurale
d'Indre-et-Loire située entre Tours et
Chinon près d'Azay-le-Rideau il remonte
à dimanche dernier le maire Fabien
Barrault a tenté d'empêcher
l'installation illicite de gens du
voyage sur un terrain de foot il s'est
rendu sur place seul et s'est retrouvé
face à un groupe de personnes qui
détruisaient un pot en béton pour
accéder au terrain bouge ou je te mets
un coup de masse dans la gueule a-t-il
alors entendu avant de se faire
bousculer il a préféré quitter les lieux
et les caravanes ont fini par pénétrer
sur le terrain pour autant il a choisi
de ne pas déposer plainte pour expliquer
ne pas avoir de représailles pour lui ou
sa commune hier mardi il a reçu le
soutien de l'Association des Maires
d'Ingré Loire elle a condamné avec la
plus grande fermeté ses actes qui
estime-t-elle en malheureusement
tendance à se répéter pour l'Association
des maires de telles agissements ne
peuvent ni ne doit ni ne doivent être
banalisés elle estime que le nécessaire
doit être fait pour que c'est fait soit
puni et que les auteurs soient condamnés
merci Valérie merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous on va parler de ce sujet en
plateau le temps de regarder la Une de
La Nouvelle République aujourd'hui on
parle d'asperges l'asperge de Touraine
qui soigne son image c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci beaucoup Valérie
Pernette d'avoir été avec nous on va
parler de ces questions de violence et
notamment violence envers les élus
puisque Valérie nous relatait une énième
agression de mer on a envie de dire les
violences envers les élus qui ont
augmenté depuis de plus de 30% depuis
l'année dernière pierre qu'est-ce qu'il
faut voir derrière ce phénomène
[Musique]
que c'était possible d'accueillir des
gens quand c'était fait dans des bonnes
conditions quand ils étaient quand vous
accueillez des réfugiés dans un dans une
communauté rurale où vous avez des
écoles qui ferment vous vous arrivez à
démontrer à démontrer aux habitants et à
vos élus que les l'école peut être
maintenue dans dans la commune donc
c'est un c'est un débat de société qu'il
faut avoir et et l'avion
c'est à la fois sur les conséquences de
la politique migratoire sur les élus
locaux
je sais pas si vous voulez qu'on aille
uniquement sur Saint-Brevin parce que
les violences sont plus générales et on
l'a vu hélas et de meilleur dramatique
dans cet hôpital hier il faut
s'interroger et vous souder Manuel Valls
il disait sur les questions et qui était
un autre de ça et qui était à notre
terrain qui était les questions
terrorisme mais cherchez à comprendre
c'est déjà cherché à vouloir excuser
alors déjà il faut se mettre de côté il
faut mettre de côté cette idée là que
chercher à comprendre très bon jusqu'ici
mais c'est pas possible il faut chercher
à comprendre non il faut chercher à
comprendre évidemment qu'il faut
chercher à comprendre les raisons pour
lesquelles il y a une montée de la
violence
à chercher à comprendre c'était déjà
vouloir excuser non je cherche pas
excuser une personne qui a commis un
acte répréhensible je cherche à
comprendre pourquoi il y a une montée de
la violence pourquoi il y a une montée
de la violence et notamment vis-à-vis
des institutions et notamment vis-à-vis
des services publics c'est ça qu'il faut
qu'on s'intéresse c'est là-dessus qu'il
faut qu'on s'interroge on est d'accord
Dominique
il a rectifié son propre propos qui qui
était ambiguïté
[Rires]
sur le fond doit être d'accord la
nécessité impérieuse de défendre les
élus en général et en particulier
s'impose car sous des prétextes ou des
motifs les plus les plus différents ils
sont aujourd'hui effectivement ils sont
ils sont apportés d'engueulade comme on
dit et même quelquefois c'est pire que
simple engueulasse les élus sont
aujourd'hui une devenue une cible il y
va
si les républicains les républicains en
général et ça fait du monde ça fait
large majorité se mobilise
ce sera une nécessité qu'il faudra
saluer mais il y va quand même de tout
simplement de la vie démocratique ça
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
quand on n'est pas d'accord l'arrivée de
si pardonnez-moi l'expression on allait
bourrer la gueule du du maire enfin
c'est pas possible ok une menace pour la
démocratie locale pour vous
pour la démocratie locale et pour la
démocratie tout court il y a il y a des
forces qui ne respectent pas qui ne
respectent pas non bien sûr ah d'accord
bon on est d'accord il y a des forces
qui nous respectent pas les règles
démocratiques et élémentaires si on
n'est pas content d'un maire si on n'est
pas content d'un élu on attend le
scrutin suivant on le prépare et cetera
et on fait en sorte de faire arbitrer la
chose par les électeurs
ça ne suffit plus de dire ça c'est il
suffit déjà beaucoup non mais c'est déjà
beaucoup parce que vous avez raison
c'est ça fait partie de l'analyse et
elle est importante mais à un moment
donné l'élu il est impuissant il finit
par être impuissant face à des citoyens
qui sont en colère le l'agent de Pôle
emploi il finit par être un puissant
face à quelqu'un qui est en colère qui
lui demande un service public de qualité
l'agent des finances publiques locales
il finit par être démuni parce qu'il n'a
pas les compétences les moyens dans ces
situations que vous décrivez vous avez
l'acte absolument dramatique qui a eu
lieu dans l'hôpital psychiatrique
qu'est-ce qui raconte il raconte que les
premières victimes sont les soignants
parce qu'il on a changé de localisation
on va élargir mais juste pour finir sur
Saint-Brevin parce que vous le disiez
pierre vous le rappeliez le maire
effectivement qui a dit qu'il n'avait
pas été soutenu par l'État mais si Eric
Dupond-Moretti était de vendre le sénay
hier c'est pas exactement ce qu'il a dit
pour moitié était auditionné par la
commission des lois il a parlé d'une
attaque contre la République en
référence aux violences de manière plus
générale qui vise les mers ces derniers
mois mais il refuse de porter le chapeau
selon lui dans la dans l'affaire Yannick
Maurice la justice et l'État n'ont pas
été laxiste écoutez
et dans cette affaire particulière de
Saint-Brevin la justice locale de ce qui
m'a été remontée n'a pas été aux abonnés
absents conformément à mes instructions
générales les parquets locaux ont donc
toujours été en contact avec ce maire
menacé et ils ont pris très au sérieux
c'est fait en ouvrant immédiatement des
enquêtes qui je l'espère vont aboutir
très prochainement
on notera quand même l'extrême prudence
dans la formulation du garde des sceaux
la justice n'a pas été aux abonnés
absentuellement c'est le moins qu'on
pouvait attendre d'autant que Pierre
avant nous faire réagir le gouvernement
suite à la démission du maire de
Saint-Brevin a annoncé une nouvelle
série de mesures pour protéger les élus
le gouvernement qui a reçu on le voit
sur cette photo qui a reçu unique Morel
la semaine dernière il a annoncé dans la
foulée un certain nombre de choses 3400
référents atteintes aux élus vont être
créés dans la gendarmerie nationale et
la police il serviront notamment
d'interlocuteurs privilégier pour les
maires le gouvernement
et aussi le renforcement du dispositif
alarme élu les maires par exemple pour
lancer un signal s'il considère qu'ils
sont en danger les signalements seront
ensuite analysés de manière prioritaire
par la police un centre d'analyse et de
lutte contre les atteintes aux élus a
aussi été lancé par le gouvernement il
permettra de cartographier les violences
commises contre nos représentants et
puis mesure très attendu l'exécutif dit
vouloir durcir les sanctions pénales
écoutez
ce sujet bien sûr de faire en sorte que
la sanction quand on quand on
s'attaque à un élu la sanction sur la
même nature que la sanction qui est
aujourd'hui
conduite auprès d'un de quelqu'un qui
s'attaque un gendarme ou un policier
mais on va passer le plus vite possible
cette loi ça va permettre malgré tout de
monter jusqu'à 10 ans d'emprisonnement
quand on s'attaque un élu et de monter à
150000 euros d'amende et si comment
était accueilli ces annonces bien mais
peut mieux faire l'association des
maires de France demande que des moyens
supplémentaires d'enquête soit donnée
aux forces de police et de gendarmerie
pour permettre à la justice de se
prononcer David sisnard le président de
l'AMF propose aussi de mettre en place
une vastitude afin de mesurer l'ampleur
exacte des agressions envers les élus
vous le rappeliez tout à l'heure Oriane
aujourd'hui selon les chiffres officiels
ces violences augmentées de 32 % en 2022
et plus de 1200 maires ont démissionné
depuis leur élections en 2020 alors on
le voit il y a des mesures est-ce
qu'elles sont suffisantes pierre est-ce
que l'État accompagne suffisamment ses
élus
j'aime pas trop l'idée que
que on va protéger encore davantage la
figure de l'éluge je pense que
évidemment il faut donner les moyens
pour que ces élus puissent
développer le mandat qui est leur dans
de bonnes conditions mais je pense que
ça passe davantage par des compétences
supplémentaires de néo-zélules locaux et
surtout des moyens supplémentaires de
Néo et du logo pour qu'ils puissent
mener des politiques qui soient des
politiques compatibles avec des attentes
et les aspirations des Français c'est ça
qui est problématiques aujourd'hui quand
vous avez assez cher à ce point les
finances locales des collectivités vous
avez des élus locaux qui se retrouvent à
devoir grever les budgets sur sur des
sur des
commentaires
quand on a asséché à ce point les
collectivités locales que les élus
locaux n'ont plus qu'à gérer des galères
qu'ils nous dont ils n'ont aucune
compétence pour pouvoir répondre et
faire face c'est un problème mais une
dernière chose quand même parce que je
trouve que quand même sur les sortes de
Saint-Brevin il y a quelque chose de
symptomatique quand on entend justement
et garder ceux qui vit dans le meilleur
des mondes possible ou jamais il est
responsable de rien mais il est tout va
mais tout va quand même très très bien
l'audition du du maire de Saint-Brévin
au Sénat est quand même assez édifiante
il raconte quand même toutes les
interpellations qu'il a pu faire sur
lesquelles il n'a eu absolument aucun
retour et quand je disais qu'il y avait
une responsabilité quand même là aussi
et c'est pas qu'une question de moyens
c'est aussi une responsabilité politique
dans le discours qui est tenu aussi par
ce gouvernement pardon mais quand on
quand on remet à l'ordre du jour la
question de la loi l'immigration où il
est question quand même de réduire le
droit d'asile et donc le droit de
d'héberger aussi un certain nombre de
réfugiés qui sont sur notre territoire
vous participez pas dans l'apaisement en
tout cas d'un climat qui serait serein
sur la question de l'accueil des
réfugiés une responsabilité de la
politique gouvernementale dans le climat
du pays Dominique pour vous aussi il y a
forcément une responsabilité du
gouvernement dans la mesure où sous un
angle sous un autre il est aux affaires
comme on dit il tient les leviers de
commandes mais ce que j'aime ce que je
j'aime à ma façon ce qui me fera
que tout est dans tout alors on est en
train de prendre les mesures on pourrait
dire il était temps des mesures pour
protéger les élus davantage qu'ils ne
l'ont été jusqu'ici d'autant que les
agressions contre les élus en général
sous un angle sous un autre de cesse de
se multiplier et à ce moment-là la
réponse est la réponse serait qu'est-ce
que c'est pas la même la réponse serait
partout si ces élus menaient une
politique plus en accord plus en phase
avec avec ce qu'attend non pas les
électeurs mais une partie des électeurs
celle qui est concernée non il faut il
faut que les élus assument leur
responsabilité ils ont été lu sur un
programme ils doivent le respecter
dialoguer organiser des compromis tout à
fait vrai c'est valable pour les uns
comme pour les autres mais non de grâce
ne mélangeons pas tout on a par exemple
puisque ça a été évoqué au passage sur
la politique d'immigration la politique
immigration n'est pas définie par
l'extrême droite pour autant pour autant
il y a des Français ont le droit
d'interroger leurs élus pour leur dire
je me pose des questions à propos de
ceci de cela quel est votre réponse on a
le droit d'en débats voilà pour dire
simplement on peut se dire que quand
même sur l'histoire de Saint-Brevin
d'abord le président de la République a
mis à peu près 11 jours à écrire un
courrier au maire de Saint-Brevin pour
lui dire le soutien qui était le sien on
aurait pu attendre une prise de position
publique lui qui est si euh manifestants
qui vont manifester
au moins soyez d'accord avec ça c'était
là vous avez un maire courageux vous
avez un meilleur courageux qui décide de
d'ouvrir un centre d'accueil pour les
droits d'asile pour les pour les exilés
en France sur son territoire vous
pourriez avoir une allocution du
Président de la République pour dire je
soutiens sommaire et oui nous allons
ouvrir des centres et il va falloir
l'entendre parce que c'est une absolue
nécessité
[Musique]
son territoire je nous conseille moi je
nous conseille à tous d'écouter ce que
va dire le maire de démissionnaire de
Saint-Brévin puisque il y a une
manifestation des forces de gauche mais
après tout j'ai jamais trop tard pour
bien faire
il prendra la parole devant sa mairie
devant la mairie qui va désormais
quitter il a déjà été effectivement
d'avoir le Sénat très rude et très
préoccupé très angoissé et quelque part
sévère mais
les choses sont tellement importantes en
jeu que c'était normal qui parle de mon
point de vue normal qui parle avec ses
vérité on va voir avec un peu de recul
il ira sûrement pas le contraire mais ce
qu'il va dire qu'est-ce qu'il va dire au
passage on verra aussi ce que diront les
manifestants de gauche
oui je note que c'est la gauche qui
mobilisait d'ailleurs sommaire c'est pas
la droite c'est pas la macronique et
derrière on dit que la gauche est
divisée etc au moins là on sait qu'elle
porte un discours
de de lutte contre l'extrême droite
c'est aussi ça que c'est aussi ça que je
veux marquer la gauche cet après-midi
Marine Le Pen aujourd'hui de venir la
plus crédible ou en tout cas une des
alternatives crédible Emmanuel Macron
vous vous dit qu'il y a danger et qu'il
y a matière est-ce que la gauche se
remobilise sur la création
le gouvernement il serait bien il serait
bien inspiré justement aussi de ne pas
être le marche-pied de Marine Le Pen
comme il le fait depuis que Emmanuel
Macron est au gouvernement elle a quand
même pris euh je sais pas le premier
mois et le raccourci fort il devait il
devait plus avoir de rassemblement
national après Emmanuel Macron vous
voyez bien qu'aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen
est quand même aux portes du pouvoir ça
fait c'est assez glaçant de le dire le
temps que la gauche justement se
mobilise on est la gauche dans cette
division dans ces contrats mais il
serait bien approximations il serait
bien que sur des sujets comme
Saint-Brevin il n'y ait pas que la
gauche qui sont mobilisés
il n'y a pas que la gauche dans les
têtes il y a tout vous nous avez tous Je
du coup tu avais avec attention euh on
va parler puisque vous parlez de la
politique du gouvernement on va parler
du climat social le gouvernement qui
présente aujourd'hui un texte en conseil
des ministres sur le partage de la
valeur alors c'est un texte qui est issu
d'un accord qui avait été trouvé entre
les partenaires sociaux et que le
gouvernement transposait est-ce que
c'est un signal qui est envoyé au
syndicat Dominique d'une volonté
d'apaisement ce texte présenté
aujourd'hui en conseil des ministres si
on veut en tout cas il a été dit et
redit que le gouvernement souhaitait
l'apaisement et souhaitait que non pas
parce que ce serait provocateur de le
formuler comme ça que la page de la
réforme des retraites soit tournée mais
d'ailleurs elle n'est pas encore
complètement mais que on passe aussi à
autre chose que ça ne tétanise pas tout
le monde bon voilà c'est intéressant ce
qui est ce qui est mis sur la table mais
on n'y est pas encore on n'est pas
encore dans le dans le basculement le
basculement ce serait simplement la vie
continue il est pas prêt d'être noué ce
dialogue pour vous pierre
quand vous serez au pouvoir d'abord
mais ce que je crois c'est que oui
d'abord la réforme des retraites on va
en parler tout à l'heure n'est pas
encore toute la page en tout cas n'est
pas totalement tournée donc je pense que
les syndicats ont aussi encore envie de
faire de peser sur ce sur ce débat là et
puis sur la question du partage de la
valeur ajoutée s'il y a pas une volonté
plus ce que je veux dire c'est que le
gouvernement c'est parfois être comment
dire
exigeant demander des contreparties
quand il s'agit je sais pas de donner
des allocations par exemple on va
demander à maintenant de pouvoir
travailler à côté donc des contreparties
on sait les imposer quand il s'agit des
Français mais quand il s'agit des chefs
d'entreprise quand on leur demande de
d'augmenter les salaires de leur de
leurs salariés bon bah là on allez ça
serait bien s'il vous plaît par
l'opération du Saint-Esprit que vous
augmentiez les salaires de vos défenser
on a vu dans l'histoire de France quand
même des moments où l'État Suède
beaucoup plus contraignant vous prenez
Grenelle Grenelle bon c'est pas non plus
extraordinaire mais il y a eu quand même
une conférence sur les salaires avec
tous les syndicats autour de la table et
au mois de mai 68 c'est peut-être que
vous nous avez là vous avez avant avant
les accords avec 4 mois quand même de
mobilisation sociale vous avez été
jusqu'à 1 2 3 4 millions de personnes
dans la rue alors peut-être qu'il y a
pas eu suffisamment
pour vous Dominique a pas eu
suffisamment de violence ou il y a pas
eu le même violence que celle de mes 68
mais en tout cas mais 68 à porter ça
quand même donc c'est ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'à l'époque où on crée
trois fois moins de richesse aujourd'hui
comment on crée trois fois plus on peut
se dire que le partage de la valeur il
est d'autant plus il pourrait d'autant
plus en la faveur des salariés surtout
quand vous voyez les chiffres qui sont
sortis cette semaine ou qui vous
montrent qu'aujourd'hui grâce à
l'inflation les dividendes ont augmenté
de manière exponentielle donc il y a un
problème d'injustice totalement notre
pays mais le gouvernement
dit quoi allez s'il vous plaît Monsieur
et Madame les entre les chefs entreprise
donnée partager la valeur quoi donc non
ça va pas il faut que ce soit beaucoup
plus contraignant il faut qu'il y ait
vraiment une obligation qui est faite
c'est pas l'état de se mêler de la
politique salariale aussi des
entreprises quand vous faites le pack de
compétitivité quand vous êtes sous
François Hollande et qu'aujourd'hui vous
continuez la même politique vous faites
des cadeaux fiscaux et des cadeaux aux
entreprises à coups de centaines de
milliards d'euros vous pouvez être un
minimum exigeant sur les contreparties
sociales et environnementales c'est une
obligation ça devrait être une
obligation même quand vous donnez des
l'argent public à des entreprises vous
devriez dire à ces entreprises ok mais
elles sont sous conditions aujourd'hui
du maintien de l'emploi d'une
rémunération plus équilibrée et d'un
respect de l'environnement et des
engagements écologiques aujourd'hui il
n'y a rien il y a des millions de
dollars il y a des millions de fois des
centaines de milliards
vous savez que c'est le premier budget
de l'État quand même les aides aux
entreprises centaines de milliards
d'euros
sur un quinquennat je pense qu'on peut
on peut parler de certaines
là mais ce que je veux dire c'est quand
vous menez une petite quand vous
annoncez une petite fiscale
je la comprends vous dites vous êtes
milliards de vous allez être aidé mais
en contrepartie vous vous engagez sur
l'emploi et sur les conditions et les
questions ça paraît logique quand même
il y a eu un nombre il y a eu un nombre
important d'emplois créés et un taux de
chômage en baisse vous voyez le là
l'entreprise comptait menu
c'est intéressant de quand Emmanuel
Macron s'est dépassé à Dunkerque il
annonce
l'investissement d'une entreprise pas
japonaise je crois que c'est taïwanaise
entreprise ayounes qui s'installe donc à
Dunkerque qui va donc créer jusqu'à 3000
emplois je crois avec un investissement
de l'état de 1,5 à 3 milliards d'euros
vous donner donc l'état l'argent public
va aider l'entreprise à son salaire à
Dunkerque si vous faites le ratio ça
veut dire le coût moyen entre 150000 et
300000 euros l'emploi en dépense
publique de l'État ça fait quand même
cher payé quand même la dépense de
l'État je sais pas si c'est plus
compliqué que ça mais en tout cas c'est
clairement des aides d'État qui vont
chercher dans chaque fois une façon de
contester une réalité l'emploi se porte
mieux je suis voilà c'est comme je suis
pour confiance
les services les finances publiques
servent à favoriser l'emploi mais vous
pouvez quand même demander à
l'entreprise taiwanaise dire ok on vous
donne de l'argent mais je veux des
engagements sur 10 15 20 30 ans en terme
de création d'emploi et sur le respect
jamais de la vie il y a pas de il y a
pas j'ai absolument pas aujourd'hui le
chômage aujourd'hui le chômage n'est
plus un problème comme il était il y a
quelques années pierre j'aimerais bien
qu'on passe le plus que la fenêtre
j'adore rire parce que c'est vraiment un
sujet passionnant mais le chômage dans
ton sapin tout le monde se réjouit
évidemment tout le monde se réjouit
c'est juste de se réjouir que les gens
soient dans l'emploi si vous voulez si
vous voulez quand vous faites lisez
politique
vous voyez on a fait plein de reportages
sur la
dispositions sur des dispositifs visages
j'en ai déçu tellement je me sens
emporter ce matin mais vous avez des
dispositifs d'États qui qui font que les
gens sont mis dans des dans des cases
dans des entreprises de manière des
stages non rémunérés ou des des
dispositifs qui permettent de ne pas
faire des périodes d'essai qui sortent
les gens du chômage donc vous sortez les
gens du chômage vous sortez des chiffres
du chômage ils sont réintégrés dans le
mode de l'emploi mais ils sont pas
rémunérés ils ont pas ils ne sort pas
avec un travail
bien la pulvérisation vous voyez bien
qu'aujourd'hui s'il y a une personne sur
6 qui est pas capable de se manger de ce
de s'alimenter parce que son salaire est
insuffisant c'est qu'il y a quand même
un problème de paupérisation du monde du
travail il y a un problème aujourd'hui
ni des niveaux de salaire qui ne permet
plus de vivre correctement ça c'est ça
ça devrait être notre principal
préoccupation on va terminer sur la
réforme des retraites et la PP Elliott
ça va vous donner des sueurs encore plus
puis après
hier on a appris que la majorité la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales qui est donc membre de la
majorité présidentielle avait saisi Eric
Coquerel député à la fille président de
la commission des finances sur la
recevabilité de ce texte disons qu'il
accroît la charge publique les dépenses
publiques et que donc la commission des
finances devait se prononcer est-ce
qu'il y a quand même un peu de fébrilité
du côté de la majorité Dominique sur le
vote de ce texte à venir le 8 juin je
sais pas si le mot fébrilité
et celui que j'aurais moi-même utilisé
mais
je vais dire marqué c'est peut-être pire
un peu de nervosité
mais là il y a quand même un gros
problème il y a un
la motion de censure n'a pas été votée à
une petite dizaine de voix près ça n'est
fallu de pas grand chose après des
débats des débats houleux et d'ailleurs
qui ont été interrompus nous revenons
pas là dessus c'est une réalité une
conséquons institutionnelle ratifié à
quelques détails près la situation et
voilà qu'un petit groupe
qui mériter le respect de ma part je les
respecte comme comme élu du peuple un
tout petit groupe intermédiaire style le
Quatrième République un peu de gauche un
peu de droite très peu nombreux et il
propose de remettre en cause à travers
des nouvelles motions de censure le
texte qui a été voté en tout cas oui oui
enfin oui si vous avez raison c'est une
proposition de loi mais effectivement il
y avait des questions dans un premier
temps l'émotion censure c'est une
proposition de loi ça change rien à rien
de mon point de vue
il y a quand même un gros problème c'est
c'est votre sixième république ça c'est
c'est manœuvres c'est manœuvres
c'est pas tout à fait
tordue on va essayer de rattraper après
coup ce qui a été voté pas voté ratifié
justement ratifié par le conseil si vous
pouviez la motion de censure vous avez
pas réussi mais pourquoi
moi non plus je suis pas député mais
vous vous cautionnez quand même cette
politique cette démarche vous espérez
vous espérez que le le le groupe puisque
c'est celui-là il faut apprendre le nom
Lio t on n'a jamais on n'avait jamais
entendu parler de ça avant bon ils ont
une petite popularité transitoire à la
faveur de la situation exceptionnelle
qui prévoit aujourd'hui vous espérez qui
vont aboutir et qu'on qu'on remettra
tout sur le qu'on remettrait tout parce
qu'en réalité ce sera pas possible
j'espère bien que ce cette démarche
aboutisse je vous dis à la raison pour
laquelle ce serait que c'est ça alors ça
vous avez repris les éléments là je vous
ai envoyé
j'arrive à être autonome ça a toujours
été le cas vous savez que si c'est et ça
date de 1982 j'étais tout seul quand le
gouvernement ne raconte pas des sottises
comme la jusqu'à la Première ministre
quand même qui nous explique quand même
que ce texte qui est déposé par l'iotte
étant qui constitutionnel comme si
maintenant la première ministre avait
des prérogatives
anticipées pour savoir
c'est différent de dire je saisirai le
Conseil constitutionnel que de dire
c'est un constitutionnel et c'est ce que
dit ce gouvernement dont Olivier Véran
aussi s'est fait le perroquet il y a pas
plus tard que hier donc un c'est c'est
dire des choses contradictoires redites
contre lise quand ils disent la même
chose
vous pouvez pas le reprocher à la gauche
d'être anti République je vais pas
rester
donc ça veut dire c'est gentil merci
Dominique je voudrais jouer à même pas
les choses mais tout le monde n'est pas
comme vous si tout le monde était à
gauche la gauche serait peut-être au
pouvoir après demain
la possibilité la bonne façon de voir
les choses
mais sur l'iode quand même ce qui est
intéressant c'est justement de voir
effectivement je pense vous avez raison
la fébrilité de ce gouvernement sur sa
stratégie d'obstruction il l'assume
enfin plus voilà
obstruction s'ils arrivent pas à faire
passer leur article 40 qui consisterait
à dire que cette réforme est jugée il
recevable parce que beaucoup trop cher
pour les finances de l'État etc sauf que
c'est pas à Madame broomprivee que donc
décidé c'est de la présidente sociale
mais c'est un monsieur Coquerel de la
France insoumise qui est le président de
la commission des finances donc si ça ne
marche pas
que je vous invite à lire qui est
vraiment très intéressant parce que il y
a plein de stratégies élaborées par ce
gouvernement pour faire en sorte que
effectivement ce texte ne passe pas mais
ce qui serait quand même assez
invraisemblable le gouvernement cette
majorité je devrais pas être inquiète ce
serait triste ne devrait pas c'est
triste parce que ça sera un échec c'est
un échec politique
ça donne une image dramatique
l'image qui a donné à voir cette la
forme de retraite la merde se sont
passés les concertations j'ai pas de
négociation les concertations l'absence
de dialogue social l'absence de
parlementaire puis aujourd'hui le
passage en force avec le 49-3 et puis la
possibilité parce que c'est le jeu
institutionnel qu'une opposition se
mette en branle pour faire abroger cette
réforme tout ça est tout à fait normal
c'est un processus normal c'est de la
politique et bien je comprends que le
gouvernement soit très fragilisé à
l'idée que leur texte qui sur lequel il
compte temps soit abrogé ça veut pas
dire que texte serait abrogé mais en
tout cas sur le plan symbolique ce
serait à catastrophique y compris 20
secondes
vous reviendrez nous en parler là ce
texte à un moment où il arrive on refera
un club avec vous
on a une de nos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]
et elle a une Steve aujourd'hui
l'émotion à Reims oui l'immense émotion
après la mort de l'infirmière tuée au
CHU de la ville si elle a une de l'Union
ce matin tous les personnels soignants
ont rendu hier un vibrant hommage à
Caren décrite comme une personne
charitable toujours au service des
autres le temps s'est figé hier lors de
la minute de silence organisé dans la
cour d'honneur de l'hôpital Maison
Blanche lundi en début d'après-midi un
homme de 59 ans a agresser au couteau
cette infirmière de 37 ans une agression
qui soulève la question de la sécurité
dans les hôpitaux de la région selon
l'Union émotion toujours dans le Nord
cette fois après la mort de trois
policiers et qui ont été tués dimanche
dans une collision ils ont été percutés
par un véhicule qui circulait à
contresens le conducteur était fortement
alcoolisé et drogué La Voix du Nord
revient aujourd'hui sur les détails de
la mort des trois agents l'accident a
également gravement blessé une jeune
fille assise dans le véhicule de la
police il se rendait au CHU de Lille
pourquoi se rendait-il au CHU de Lille
et bien parce que pour des raisons
budgétaires des raisons comptables
départements de médecine légale à fermer
à rouba du coup et bien les policiers
sont désormais contraints de se rendre à
Lille pour comment l'espèce faire
examiner les potentiels victimes
d'agression et on a pris ce matin
qu'Emmanuel Macron se rendra demain à
Roubaix pour rendre hommage à ces trois
policiers autre titre elle a une de la
presse régionale stop à la violence oui
c'est le cri d'alarme qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui en Une de La Dépêche du Midi
soignant prof élus trop c'est trop par
quel processus insidieux et désespéré
nos démocraties ont-elles sombrées dans
la brutalité se demande le journal dans
son édito il faut réagir et vite sinon
notre société est menacée par une grande
démission chez les soignants les
enseignants les mers les policiers les
gendarmes et on devine écrit à des
pêches du midi à qui tout cela profitera
à l'occasion des prochaines élections
nous sommes en Bretagne pour terminer
on va en Bretagne en ce qui concerne le
tourisme la région est devenue une
région écolo regardez la Une de télégram
le journal revient sur la mue du
tourisme breton une étude révélé hier
monde que les crises ont bousculé la
région brexit covid réchauffement
climatique la Bretagne s'adapte et
séduit toujours autant en 2022 la
fréquentation à renoué avec les niveaux
d'avant covid et puis on apprend que
depuis le brexit les Allemands sont
devenus la première clientèle étrangère
et que la préoccupation écolo progresse
très fortement merci
la Une de politique ça veut dire cette
semaine ça ça va vous ça va ça va vous
plaire Dominique attention
Macron 2 sommes-nous toujours libre oui
on s'a interrogé
par une illustratrice que j'aime
beaucoup qui s'appelle
Anne-Sophie Amiot qui allait
donner le 49-3 le côté
évidemment de surveillance les drones
tous ces interrogations qui nous
interrogent justement et qui nous
intéresse légitimement c'est pas du tout
une provocation ce titre on s'interroge
vraiment sur le la question des libertés
et de nos droits dans notre pays il faut
toujours défendre la liberté mais on est
on est libre assurez-moi
d'avoir été avec nous merci Steve pour
voir ou revoir ce débat passionné
passionnant c'est sur notre nouvelle
plateforme public sénat.fr prochain
rendez-vous à 15h la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement et à 18h
Thomas Hulk pour sens publique très
bonne journée à demain
[Musique]